DRAGIC.
HE GOES, A THREE TO TIE IT AT
107.
AND NOW MILWAUKEE WITH THE SHOT
CLOCK TURNED OFF CAN HOLD FOR A
POTENTIAL GAME WINNER.
CROWD RISING TO ITS FEET.
MIDDLETON, FIVE SECONDS LEFT IN
OVERTIME.
MIDDLETON WITH TWO, THERE GOES
RIGHT BY HIM.
SEE, ROBINSON TRIES TO PICK UP
HERE, RIGHT THERE.
THERE'S THE FADE.
NOT ONLY DOES HE ELEVATE, BUT HE
GETS THE FADE AND HE
>> Kevin: BUCKS HAVE BEEN A
NUMBER ONE SEED THE LAST TWO
SEASONS.
NUMBER THREE SEED COMING INTO
THIS PARTICULAR UP AND
OFF, AND 14 ON THE SHOT CLOCK.
>> Reggie: YOU'RE WONDERING
FOUNTAIN LENGTH OF GIANNIS IS T
JIGGLED UP THERE.
FLOATING UNTOUCHED INSIDE AND
TAKES IT IN FOR TWO IS JRUE
HOLIDAY.
THEY GO INSIDE.
NICE KNOCK-AWAY BY PORTIS.
FORBES WILL SAVE IT AND BACK TO
JRUE HOLIDAY.
DOWN THE MIDDLE.
PUTS ON THE BRAKES AND FIRES! I.
USES HIS CUTTING TO GET IN THERE
AND PICK IT UP AND OVER LOPEZ.
CONNAUGHTON HAS GOT IT AND KHRIS
MIDDLETON IS
IT WILL GO ON MIAMI AND I THINK
IGUODALA PICKS IT UP.
>> Reggie: BEAUTIFUL BALL
MOVEMENT ANDMISS.
ALWAYS JUMPING IN THERE, BUT
THAT BALL WAS DEFINITELY IN THE
CYLINDER RIGHT THERE.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO STOP TEAMS AND CON
FINALISTS WITH DENVER AND L.A.
IN THE WEST, BOSTON OF COURSE
AND MIAMI, AND ALL OF THE
INJURIES THEY'VE ENDURED, LOSING
JAYLEN BROWN --
OH, GIANNIS FIRES ONE DOWN